สวัสดีค่ะครูปุ๊กสวัสดีค่ะครูบีสวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียนทุกคนค่ะสวัสดีนักเรียนทุกคนเช่น
กันค่ะค่ะขอต้อนรับนักเรียนทุกคนนะคะเข้า
สู่ห้องเรียนภาษาไทยห้องเรียน
comprehensible ไทยค่ะอืเป็นห้องเรียน
ภาษาไทยแบบธรรมชาตินะคะอ่าวันนี้เราก็มา
เจอกันอีกแล้วค่ะครูปุ๊กใช่เราต้องเจอกัน
บ่อยๆค่ะใช่นะคะเรามาเจอกันในวันอะไรวัน
นี้วันศุกร์ค่ะนะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันนี้
วันที่ 1 ค่ะเดือนอะไรคะมีนาคมค่ะเป็น
เดือนที่ 3 แล้วอืปีพ.ศรอคะ
2567 ค่ะปีค.ศลอคะ
2024 ค่ะนะวันนี้เนี่ยวันที่ 1 แล้วเนา
เป็นวันศุกร์นะคะตรงกับวันที่ 1 เดือน
มีนาคมปีพุทธศักราช
2567 ปีคริสตศักราช
2024 ค่ะนะวันที่ 1 อ่าเดือนที่ 3 นะ
เดือนมีนาคมแล้วค่ะโอ้โหแป๊บเดียวอเอ้อ
เดือนมกราคมกุมภาพันธ์มีนาคมเริ่มต้น
มีนาคมแล้วนะคะวันที่ 1 มีเงินมากๆใช่
มั้ยคะครูปุ๊กวันที่ 1 เนี่ยเอ่อคิดว่า
ค่ะคือใครทำงานออฟฟิศเนี่ยเขาคก็จะได้
เงินเนาะบางบริษัทเนี่ยเขาคจะให้วันที่
อาจจะวันสุดท้ายของเดือนอาจจะเป็นอย่าง
เดือนที่แล้วก็วันที่ 29 ใช่มยหรือบาง
เดือนอาจจะเป็น 30 หรือ 31 หรือบางออฟฟิศ
ก็อาจจะให้วันที่ 1
อ่าเนาะก็แล้วแต่ออฟฟิศแต่ว่าหลายๆคนก็มี
เงินแล้ว
นหรือบางคนอาจจะมาหาเงินในวันนี้
ค่ะอ่ะนะก็คิดว่าวันที่ 1 เนี่ยยังเป็น
วันที่ยังมีเงินอยู่นะคะเพราะบางคนเนี่ย
ครูปุ๊กบอกว่าบางออฟฟิศให้วันที่ 1 ถึง
วันที่ 5 เนาะอ่าบางคนนี่เงินอาจจะออกวัน
ที่ 5 ก็ได้นะคะแต่คนที่ออฟฟิศให้เงิน
ตั้งแต่วันที่ 29 เมื่อวานเนี้ยนะคะเดือน
เดือนกุมภาพันธ์นะคะเงินอาจจะหมดแล้ว
เพราะว่าจ่ายอพาร์ทเมนต์จ่ายค่าทศัพท์แต่
คนที่บริษัทให้วันที่ 1 เนี่ยวันนี้มี
เงินไงครูปุ๊กอ่าแต่ว่าเดี๋ยวก็ต้องจ่าย
ใช่มั้ยใช่นะคะมีเงินเนี่ยก็ต้องไปกิน
อะไรที่มันอร่อยๆอยากกินอะไรก็ต้องซื้อนะ
คะอืมนะก็เอ่อต้นเดือนนะหมายถึงวันที่ 1
วันที่ 2 วันที่ 3 วันที่ 4 วันที่ 5
อย่างเงี้ยก็ยังอยู่ต้นเดือนอยากกินอะไร
ก็กินได้เพราะว่ามีเงินอืม
อ้านะเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยเราไปกินอะไรกันดี
คะครู
บีช่วงเวลาบ่ายๆนี้หรอคะเพราะว่าตอน
เที่ยงนี้ก็กินข้าวแล้วค่ะอิ่มละกินข้าว
กับต้มยำไก่ก็ข้าวกับเนื้อสัตว์ก็เป็น
อาหารที่แบบมีรสชาติแบบ
อร่อยรสชาติอร่อยนะแต่มันเป็นอาหารคาวไง
ปูปุ๊กอ่ามันก็จะมีรสชาติหวานเปรี้ยวเผ็ด
เค็มต้องง 4 รสนะด้วยกันอ่าแล้วครูบีก็
กินต้มยำไก่แล้วก็มีข้าวสวยนะคะก็รู้สึก
อิ่มนะแต่ว่ายังอยากกินอิ่มอาหารนะอาหาร
ขาวแต่ยังอยากกินอย่างอื่นค่ะ
อ๋ออยากกินอะไรหวานๆใช่
มยถูกต้องค่ะแปลว่าครูปุ๊กเนี่ยก็เพิ่ง
กินข้าวอิ่มมาเอ่าครูปุ๊กเนี่ยร้อนมากๆ
ใช่มยก็เลยคิดถึงไอศกรีมหวานๆเย็นๆชื่นใจ
ค่ะโหถ้าคิดถึงไอศครีมเนี่ยหวานๆเนี่ย
ต้องไปไปกินที่ร้านเลยนะครูปุ๊กอ่าใช่ค่ะ
เพราะว่ากินที่ร้านเนี่ยมันจะไม่ละลายไง
ถ้าซื้อกลับมาที่บ้านเนี่ยมันอาจจะแบบบาย
ๆละลายเป็นน้ำโอแน่นอนเพราะตอนนี้อากาศ
ร้อนมากครูปุ๊กนะประเทศไทยตอนนี้ร้อนมาก
นะูปุ๊กถ้าอยากกินไอศครีมต้องไปแบบเป็น
เอ่อที่ห้างสรรพสินค้ามีแอร์เย็นๆใช่มั้ย
อย่างเ่อเซ็นทรัลนะคะเดมอนะบิ๊กซีโลตัส
เนี่ยเขาจะมีไอศครีม Daily  Queen
สวนเส้น
อ่าแต่ๆอ่าไปเซเว่นอว่นก็ได้ก็มี
ไอศครีมก็จะเป็นไอศกรีมแบบถ้วยๆนะที่เค้า
เอาใตะตู้แช่ไว้นะแล้วก็เป็นไอศกรีมแท่ง
ค่ะมีค่ะอยู่ในตู้เย็นอ๋อครูปุ๊กเนี่ย
ซื้อไอศกรีมเอาไว้ในตู้เย็นแปลว่าครูปุ๊ก
นี่ชอบกินอะไรหวานๆนะอ้าใช่ค่ะเป็นคนหวาน
ๆก็เลยชอบกินอะไรหวานๆค่ะของหวานเนี่ยชอบ
มากจริงๆครูบุ๊กชอบกินขนมหวานมากกว่ากิน
ข้าว
ค่ะเออถ้าพูดไปแล้วเนี่ยประเทศไทยเนี่ยมี
ของหวานเยอะนะเป็นพวกขนมแม้แต่อาหารแกง
เนี่ยเรายังมีรสชาติหวานด้วยเลยเนาะถูก
ต้องค่ะเพราะว่าถ้ารสมันแบบไม่ไม่มีรส
หวานเนี่ยมันจะไม่อร่อยเนาะรสชาติที่หวาน
เนี่ยมันก็จะทำให้รสชาติทั้งหมดมันรวมกัน
กลมกล่อมมากขึ้นนะกลมกล่อมหมายถึงรสชาติ
เนี่ยมันจะมี 4 เนาะ 4 อย่างก็คือเปรี้ยว
หวานเผ็ดเค็มนะน้ยที่สุดมันจะมีมี 4
อย่างหลายๆอย่างก็จะมีรส 4 รสด้วยกัน
เนี่ยแหละนะพอดีพอดีกันมันก็จะทำให้รส
ชาติเนี่ยมันเป็นรสชาติที่อร่อยถูกปากคน
ไทยอค่ะถ้าเกิดเราพูดถึงเรื่องหวานเนาะรส
ชาติหวานเนี่ยจริงๆแล้วไม่ว่าจะเป็นอาหาร
ไทยขนมไทยนะคะหรือ
ไอศกรีมไม่ใช่เวเซ่นก็ได้นะเป็นไอศครีม
แบบคนไทยนะไอศครีมที่ทำมาจากกะทิอย่าง
เงี้ยค่ะูปุ๊กจะเห็นว่าความหวานเนี่ยจริง
ๆมันมาจากได้มาจากอะไรหลๆายอย่างนะไม่ไม่
ได้จำเป็นต้องเป็นน้ำตาลนะคะอืมถึงน้ำตาล
เองนมันก็มีน้ำตาลที่หลายๆชนิดนะครูบีก็
ไม่ใช่มีน้ำตาลแค่อย่างเดียวแต่ว่าด้วย
อาหารไทยหรือขนมไทยนะก็ความหวายเนี่ยมัน
จะเข้ากับเนื้อแล้วแต่เนาะว่าทำอะไรจะใส่
น้ำตาลแบบไหนจะใส่ความหวาแบบไหนลงไปเพื่อ
ให้ความอร่อยเนี่ยมากขึ้นอ่าถ้าอย่างงั้น
เนี่ยวันเนี้เรามาทำความรู้จัก
ว่าความหวานเนี่ยมันมาจากอะไรบ้างดีกว่า
ครูปุ๊กได้มาจากอะไร
อืนะเพราะว่าอย่างกาแฟเนี่ยถ้าเราไปใส่
น้ำตาลอย่างอื่นไม่ใช่น้ำตาลทรายหรือว่า
น้ำตาลก้อนเนาะนะมันก็อาจจะทำให้รสชาติ
มันเปลี่ยนแล้วมันไม่อร่อยค่ะนะอาหารบาง
อย่างก็ต้องใส่นน้ำตาลที่ไม่เหมือนกัน
เพราะฉะนั้นวันนี้เนี่ยครูปุ๊กจะพาไปแนะ
นำให้รู้จักน้ำตาลก่อนอืได้เลยค่ะนะน้ำ
ตาลความหวานจากน้ำตาลเนี่ยเราได้มาจาก
อะไรแล้วนะครูก็แนะนำให้พอเข้าใจนิดนึงเน
เพราะเราไม่ได้เอาไปถึงวิธีการทำโดยตรงนะ
อ่าแค่ให้รู้ว่าความหวานเนี่ยได้มาจากน้ำ
ตาลมีน้ำตาลแบบไหนบ้างอ่าอใช่มยบางอย่าง
ก็อาจจะมาจากธรรมชาติอย่างงี้เนาะครูปุ๊ก
โอ้ส่วนใหญ่แล้วก็คือมันต้องเริ่มต้นมา
จากวัตถุดิบที่เป็น
ธรรมชาติแล้วบางอย่างเนี่ยเขาก็เอามาผ่าน
กระบวนการทางเคมีแล้วก็ออกมาเป็นความหวาน
ก็ได้หรือเอาความหวานจากธรรมชาติมาใช้เลย
ก็ได้นะรูบีอืงั้นก็พาไปเลยค่ะครูปุ๊ก
อยากรู้จักล่ะค่ะนี่ค่ะนะอันเนี้ยแค่น้ำ
ตาลอย่างเดียวนะอืที่นักเรียนเห็นเนี่ยก็
จะมีทั้งน้ำตาลตาลตะโนดน้ำตาลมะพร้าวน้ำ
ตาลทรายขาวน้ำตาลทรายแดงน้ำตาลทรายสีทอง
น้ำตาลอ้อยอันนี้คือน้ำตาลทั้งหมดที่มี
ใช่ค่ะทั้งหมดมีรสชาติหวานใช่ค่ะเพียงแต่
หวานของเขาคเนี่ยจะไม่เหมือนกันนะเราบอก
ว่าอย่างน้ำตาลทรายขาวเนี่ยนะมันก็จะมีรส
ชาติที่แบบหวานแบบหวานวานหวานน่ะเราเรียก
หวานแหลมหมายถึงว่ามันจะมีความหวานอย่าง
เดียวเลยนะก็น้ำตาลทรายขาวเนี่ยเป็นน้ำ
ตาลที่ทุกทุกคนรู้จักอยู่แล้วแล้วก็ใช้
เป็นประจำเนาะส่วนมากเนี่ยอ่าเราก็จะเห็น
ว่าเวลาเราดื่มกาแฟใช่มยก็จะมีน้ำตาใสขาว
นะคะใช่ค่ะเพราะว่าน้ำตาลทรายขาวเนี่ย 1
สีมันไม่ทำให้สีของของที่เราใส่ไปอ่ะมัน
เปลี่ยนเพราะมันเป็นสีขาวถูกมยใส่กาแฟมัน
ก็ก็ยังเป็นสีกาแฟอยู่ค่ะนะใส่ในต้มยำใส่
ในอะไรมันก็ยังเป็นคงเป็นสีของมันอยู่นะ
ข้อที่ 2 ก็คือมันจะเป็นรสชาติหวานอย่าง
เดียวไม่มีรสอื่นผสมอืแล้วน้ำตาลทรายขาว
เท่าที่ครูบีใช้นะแล้วก็เวลาดมเนี่ยมันจะ
ไม่ค่อยมีกลิ่นหอมอืใช่มันจะให้รสหวาน
อย่างเดียวรสชาติหวานอย่างเดียวแต่ว่ามัน
ไม่มีกลิ่นค่ะความหอมก็เลยอะไรที่เรา
ต้องการให้รสชาติของวัตถุดิบที่เราใช้อ่ะ
มันมีกลิ่นขึ้นมาโดยไม่มีกลิ่นอื่นรบกวน
แต่ต้องมีความหวานเค้าก็จะใช้น้ำตาลทราย
เนี่ยแหละค่ะน้ำตาลทรายขาวนะในการใช้แต่
ถ้าขนมไทยอ่ะบางอย่างเนาะที่เราต้องการ
แบบให้มันแบบมีความไม่หวานมากไม่หวานแหลม
เนาะเราก็อาจจะใช้น้ำตาลที่มาจากมะพร้าวเ
อันที่ 2 นี้เนาะเป็นน้ำตาลที่มาจาก
มะพร้าวซึ่งบางทีบางคนอาจจะเรียกน้ำตาล
ปี๊บน้ำตาลปึกได้ค่ะแล้วแต่อะไรที่เขาไป
ใส่เนาะตอนทำทำเสร็จแล้วมาใส่นะเราก็
เรียกในแต่ละอย่างอาจจะเปลี่ยนไปนะแต่ว่า
ทำมาจากมะพร้าวเดี๋ยวเราค่อยมาดูเนาะนะ
แล้วก็มันก็จะทำให้ความหวานเนี่ยมันไม่
ได้หวานตี๊ดแต่มันจะหวานมันๆค่ะแล้วก็มี
กลิ่นหอมเหมือนมนักเรียนกินกะทิมะพร้าว
อย่างเงี้ยค่ะนะมันก็เลยจะมีกลิ่นหอมด้วย
อันนี้เหมาะกับการทำขนมไทยมากๆนะอนะก็
เห็นเลยค่ะขนมไทยข้างบนนั
นะสีเหลืองๆนะคะก็คือส่วนมากก็ทำมาจากน้ำ
ตาลมะพร้าวคือน้ำตาลแต่ละอย่างเนี่ยก็
เหมาะสำหรับทำขนมเหมาะสำหรับทำอาหารเหมาะ
สำหรับทำเครื่องดื่มชากาแฟคะเพราะฉะนั้น
เนี่ยอื่นๆเี่ก็ก็แล้วแต่เราอ่ะที่เราจะ
ไปใส่เนาะเพื่อให้มันมีรสชาติแล้วก็กลิ่น
นะเห็นมยเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยอาหารไทยก็เลย
แบบมีแต่ละอย่างจะใส่อาจจะใส่น้ำตาลที่
ไม่เหมือนกันให้ความหวานที่ไม่เหมือนกัน
ค่ะ
นะทีนี้เนี่ยเราก็มาดูก่อนเนาะว่าอันดับ
แรกเนี่ยูบุ๊กจะพาไปรู้จักความหวานที่เรา
จะได้มาเนี่ยได้มาจากอะไรอืมอย่างเมื่อ
กี้ครูปุ๊กบอกว่าอ่าได้มาจาก
อ่าอะไรนะน้ำตาลมะพร้าวอืแล้วก็น้ำตาลที่
มาจากต้นตาลใช่มลูกตาลเหรอลูกตาลหรือต้น
ตาลเดี๋ยวต้องไปูต้นตานค่ะอ่าต้นตาลค่ะ
นักเรียนอาจจะบอกเอ้ยต้นตาลเป็นยังไงอ่ะ
เดี๋ยวูเปิดให้ดูเลยค่ะว่าต้นตาลเนี่ยมัน
ยังไงนะมันเหมือนต้นมะพร้าวมั้ยนี่ค่ะต้น
ตาลนะต้นตาลเนี่ยมันจะเป็นต้นไม้ที่สูง
เป็นปาล์มชนิดนึงนะแต่เราเรียกว่าต้นตาล
นะความสูงเนี่ยจะสูงสูงๆนะสูงขึ้นไป
เรื่อยๆค่ะแล้วก็เก็บไปเรื่อยๆเหมือน
มะพร้าวนั่นแหละค่ะนะแต่ว่าใบของเขาเนี่ย
จะไม่เหมือนมะพร้าวนักเรียนสังเกตดูนะเจะ
มีก้านขึ้นมาแล้วก็มีใบๆกลมๆเนาะใบเา้าจะ
ออกหยิกๆๆกลมๆแต่มันจะไม่เหมือนอันนี้ก็
มีเอ่อเราเรียกว่าต้นตาลหรือบางคนอาจจะ
บอกว่าตตาลโตนดน้ำตาลของตาลโตนดเนี่ยนะ
หอมจะหอมมากนะแล้วก็มีน้ำตาลที่ได้มาจาก
มะพร้าวเห็นมั้ยใบมะพร้าวกับใบตาลเนี่ย
ไม่เหมือนกันอื
นะแล้วก็มีน้ำตาลที่ได้มาจากอ้อยค่ะอืมนะ
นเรียนน่าจะรู้จักอ้อยอันนี้นะที่เอามาทำ
น้ำตาลทรายขาวเนี่ยละค่ะทรายขาวทรายแดง
น้ำตาลอ้อยนะอืเนี่ยอันเนี้ย
ยิ่งน้ำตาลอ้อยเนี่ยเราก็จะรู้จักกันเนาะ
ว่าเราเอามาเอาอ้อยมาทำนะเป็นน้ำตาลทราย
น้ำตาลทรายขาวแบบนี้นะก็เอาไปผ่านเอาไป
โรงงานแล้วก็บีบน้ำออกมาแล้วก็ไปทำให้มัน
เนี่ยน้ำมันบายๆออกไปเหลือแต่น้ำตาลนะ
ความหวานมันก็จะหว้าย
หวานอันนี้น้ำตาลทรายขาวเนี่ยมาจากจาก
อ้อยนะทำมาจากอ้อยนะส่วนมากอืใช่ค่ะอัน
นี้ก็จะเป็นน้ำตาลไทรแดงอืน้ำตาลไทรแดง
เนี่ยก็คือมันผ่านกระบวนการขัดสีน้อยกว่า
เนาะนะก็จะทำให้มันยังมีแบบความเป็นกลิ่น
ของอ้อยอ่ะยังอยู่เยอะค่ะใช่เพราะว่าถ้า
ครูปุ๊กดื่มอ่า
อเมริกาโน่แล้วใส่น้ำตาลทรายแดงจะอร่อย
กว่าน้ำตาลทรายขาวนะคะเพราะมันจะมีกลิ่น
หอมอืรสชาติอร่อยต่างกันนะครูปุ๊กคือด้วย
กลิ่นของมันไงอืของมันที่มันไม่เหมือนกัน
นะแล้วก็ความหวานเนี่ยอันนี้ก็จะหวานน้อย
กว่าน้ำตาลทรายขาวนะใช่ความรู้สึกครูปุ๊ก
นะว่ามันน้อยกว่าจริงๆมันทำมาจักเหมือน
กันแต่ด้วยผ่านกระบวนการหรือการทำเนี่ยนะ
สเต็ปของการทำเนี่ยมันยังไม่ได้ขัดสีอะไร
มากเขาก็ยังมีความมีกลิ่นที่ยังมี
ธรรมชาติเนาะที่เหมือนกับกลิ่นของอ้อยอ่ะ
อเถึงบอกว่าเวลาใส่เครื่องดื่มมันจะหวาน
พอดีไงคะถ้าน้ำตาลทรายขาวมันจะหวานมากอ่า
มันหวานมากเกินไปอย่างเงี้ยค่ะปุุกค่ะนะ
เพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยก็ต้องเลือกใส่แล้วแต่
ว่ามันจะมีกลิ่นไงที่ครูปุ๊กบอกว่าบางที
เนี่ยกลิ่นของน้ำตาลเนี่ยมันอาจจะไปรบกวน
กลิ่นของสิ่งที่เราทำอ่ะอืเหมือเอ่ออย่าง
เช่นถ้านักเรียนอยากให้กลิ่นของ
เอ่ออะไรอ่ะเอ่อผลไม้ใช่มั้ยอาจจะแบบเอา
ไปใส่ในผลไม้แล้วไม่อยากให้มันกลิ่นอื่น
รบกวนเหมือนใส่สตรอเบอร์รี่อย่างเงี้ยนะ
เอาไปทำปั่นสตรอเบอร์รี่ใช่มยนะแล้วก็ใส่
น้ำตาลถ้าเป็นน้ำตาลแดะน้ำตาลไทรขาวเนี่ย
เอาไปทำน้ำเชื่อมเนี่ยมันจะไม่มีกลิ่นแต่
ถ้าน้ำตาลไทรแดงเนี่ยเอาไปทำน้ำเชื่อมนะ
ไปต้มใส่น้ำเนี่ยแล้วก็มาใส่เนี่ยมันก็จะ
มีกลิ่นน้ำตาลไทรแดงอ่ะนะที่เป็นกลิ่นของ
อ้อยแล้วมันก็เป็นมันจะไปตัดกับกลิ่น
สตรอว์เบอร์รี่ทำให้กลิ่นสตรอว์เบอร์รี่แ
แทนที่มันจะมากมันก็น้อยลงเพราะว่าไอ้
กลิ่นเยมันไปรบกวนไงอืมพูถึงบอกว่าบาง
อย่างต้องใช้ใช้กลิ่นบางอย่างเนี่ยไม่
อยากมีกลิ่นอืก็คือคือต้องการความหวานนะ
อ่าพูดเข้าใจง่ายๆคืออย่างเช่นเครื่อง
ดื่มที่ต้องการความหวานแต่ยังอยากได้
กลิ่นสตอเบอร์รี่กลิ่นลิ้นจี่นะเพราะครู
บีเพิ่งจะปั่นทำน้ำปั่นไปเนาะมีลูกค้า
สั่งลิ้นจีปั่นเนี่ยคือครูบีจะไม่ใช้น้ำ
ตาลทรายแดงนะคะเพราะว่ามันจะทำให้กลิ่น
ลิ้นจี่สตรอเบอร์รี่เนี่ยลดลงอืครูบีก็
ใช้น้ำตาลทรายขาวแต่ไม่ใช่เป็นน้ำตาลทราย
ขาวที่เป็นเม็ดนะคะก็คือเป็นน้ำเชื่อมอื
นะหรือว่าบางคนก็อาจจะเรียกไซรับนะคะ
เพราะว่าเวลาเราไปสั่งเอ่อที่ร้านกาแฟ
ร้านเครื่องดื่มบางทีลูกค้าก็จะบอกเอ่อ
ใส่ไซรับค่ะไม่พูดภาษาไทยอ่ะนะภาษาไทยก็
คือน้ำเชื่อมนะคะเชื่อมก็คือมีน้ำแล้วก็
ไปต้มต้มๆให้เดือดเนาะใส่น้ำตาลเนี่ยให้
มันเดด 100 องศเซซแล้วก็บูๆๆๆนะเอาความ
เหนียวเท่ากับที่เราต้องการก็เสร็จแล้ว
น้ำเชื่อพอได้น้ำเชื่อมใช่มก็ใส่น้ำผลไม้
เนาะที่เป็นลิ้นจี่หรือว่าสตอเบอร์รี่
หรือแอปเปิ้ลกีวี่ก็ได้มันจะมีกลิ่นของ
ลิ้นจี่มันจะหอมลิ้นจี่ใช่มยคะอ่ะพอใส่
น้ำน้ำเชื่อมเข้าไปปุ๊บก็ยังได้กลิ่นลิ้น
จี่แต่ถ้าใส่น้ำตาลแดงน้ำตาลทรายแดงมันจะ
ไปทำให้กลิ่นลิ้นจี่กลิ่นสตรอเบอร์รี่
กลิ่นกีวี่น่ะลดลงลงมันจะไม่อร่อยไงครู
ปุ๊กนี่แหละเราก็เลยต้องเลือกใช้นะว่าเรา
จะใช้น้ำตาลทรายแดงหรือน้ำตาลทรายขาวอ่า
แต่คนไทยก็ปวดหัวเหมือนกันนะครูบีเพราะ
ว่ามันมีอีกอันนึงที่เค้าเรียกเหมือนกัน
น่ะน้ำตาลทรายแดงน้ำตาลทรายแดงอแต่จริงๆ
อ่ะอันเนี้ยครูปุ๊กจะเรียกเป็นน้ำตาลแดง
อืนะที่บ้านจะเรียกน้ำตาลแดงแต่อันเนี้ย
น้ำตาลทรายแดงอือนนักเรียนสีมันจะไม่แดง
หรอกแต่ว่าสีมันมันมันจะเข้มกว่ากันเนาะ
แล้วก็กลิ่นเนี่ยกลิ่นจะไม่เหมือนกันนะ
เพราะว่าอันเนี้ยมันละเอียดกว่าเนาอันแรก
เนาะละเอียดมันจะเป็นผงๆมากกว่านะแต่ว่า
กลิ่นมันจะมีกลิ่นเฉพาะตัวเนาะกลิ่นมันจะ
มากกว่ามากกว่าน้ำตาลทรายแดงแบบนี้นะน้ำ
ตาลแดงเยก็คือมันจะมากกว่ากลิ่นมันจะอ่า
ถ้าถ้าให้เปรียบเทียบดูเนี่ยเนี่ยฝั่งที่
เป็นน้ำตาลแดงที่สีเข้มกว่าเนี่ยสีน้ำตาล
เลยเนี่ยเป็นผงๆเนี่ยอันนี้คือใส่เครื่อง
ดื่มเนี่ยจะอร่อยกว่าเพราะว่ามันไม่หวาน
มากเกินไปนะแล้วก็จะราคาแพงกว่าส่วนที่
เป็นเม็ดๆน้ำตาลทรายแดงเนี่ยคือมันจะหวาน
มากกว่านะแต่ก็หอมแต่อีกอันนึงที่เป็นสี
น้ำตาลเลยเนี่ยมันจะหอมพอดีอ่ะนะก็คือมัน
รู้สึกว่ามันไม่ได้หวานมากแต่ว่ามันจะ
หวานแบบแบบไม่รู้มันมันความหวานมันจะกลม
กล่อมมากกว่ามันเหมือนความหวานมันจะไม่ด
แหลมไปนะจนแบบบางทีเนี่ยมันจัดตัวกันเป็น
ก้อนก้อนเล็กๆเนาะน้ำตาลแดงที่ครูปูบอก
อันแรกเนาะอันแรกอ่ะก็เวลาเด็กๆอ่ะบางที
เห็นมันชื้นมันก็จะจับตัวกันเป็นก้อนก็จะ
เอามากินแทนทอฟฟี้หรือเป็นลูกอมอย่าง
เงี้ยนะเป็นพวกเอ่อผมยิ้มแบบเนี้ยมันจะ
อร่อยนะเพราะว่ามันเหมือนเป็นความหวานที่
เหมือนคุณกินช็อกโกแลตแล้วแบบไม่ได้หวาน
เกินไปอ่ะแล้วก็เหมือนกินมันก็จะละลายใน
ปากใช่มพอเราเอาเข้าปากปุ๊บอืก็ละลายแล้ว
มันอร่อยแล้วมันจะคล้ายๆผงโอตินคล้ายๆผง
โกโก้คล้ายๆเอ่อผงไมโลอย่างเงี้ยค่ะอร่อย
อรนะคะอืถ้านักเรียนนึกไม่ออกเนี่ยมันมี
ของที่เขานิยมมาใส่เนาะอือย่างเช่นเต้า
ฮวยอันนี้เราเรียกเมนูชื่อเต้าฮวยเนาก็
คือเป็นเต้าหู้นะเต้าหู้แล้วก็เอาใส่กับ
น้ำขิงมันจะมีน้ำขิงนะแล้วก็เป็นเต้าหู้
แล้วก็จะมีปลาท่องโก๋แต่เป็นปลาท่องโก๋
ที่ทอดกรอบๆตัวเล็กๆเนาะแต่บางคนไม่มีก็
อาจจะใช้ปอท่องโกตัวใหญ่ๆแบบนี้ก็ได้แล้ว
ก็หั่นๆๆแล้วก็ใส่ลงไปในน้ำขิงโหเวลากิน
กับน้ำขิงเนี่ยนะมันจะอร่อยมากนะครูบีน้ำ
ขิงร้อนอุ่นๆใช่ค่ะมันจะหอมแล้วก็ไม่หวาน
แหลมนะไม่หวานเกินไปมันพอดีค่ะมันจะทำให้
รสชาติของขิงเนี่ยยังเป็นขิงทำให้รสชาติ
ของกาแฟยังเป็นกาแฟอ่ารสชาติเครื่องบ
อันเนี้ยมันมันเหมือนมันจะเข้ากับน้ำขิง
อ่ะนักเรียนมันจะเข้ากันแบบพอได้กลิ่น
เนี้ยมันไม่ได้ไปตัดให้แบบมันช่วยทำ
ให้มันหอมขึ้นน่ะอืทำให้กลิ่นน้ำขิงเนี่ย
หอมน้ำขิงมากขึ้นใช่่เพราะว่าน้ำตาลแดง
ที่ครูปุ๊กบอกเนี่ยถ้าเราใส่กาแฟดำเนี่ย
มันจะทำให้กาแฟกาแฟดำน่ะมันจะเป็นกลิ่น
หอมของกาแฟอยู่แล้วมันจะช่วยให้กลิ่นหอม
มากขึ้นเช่นกันนะคะทางร้านที่เคทำเครื่อง
ดื่มเก็ใช้น้ำตาลแดงนี่แหละค่ะอือเห็นม
หรือว่านักเรียนอาจจะไปเจอร้านเฉ่าก๊วยนะ
มันเป็นแบบของคนจีนนะไทยจีนเขาก็จะทำขึ้น
มาเหมือนกันเนี่ยมันมาจากต้นไม้ชนิดนึง
แล้วเอามาทำเป็นเฉาก๊วยมันเป็นเหมือนวุ้น
นะเหมือนเยลลี่นะแล้วเขาก็จะใส่เขาก็จะ
เอาไอ้สีดำๆเนี่ยแหละก็คือเฉาก๊วยแล้วก็
ใส่ด้วยน้ำตาลแดงนะจะโรยน้ำตาลแดงแล้วก็
ใส่น้ำแข็งนะน้ำอันนี้ก็จะจะเป็นน้ำ
เชื่อมก็เหมือนไซรับอ่ะก็คือเอาน้ำตาลแดง
นี่แหละเอาไปต้มกับน้ำนะแล้วก็มีน้ำน้ำ
เฉาก๊วยออกมาเนี่ยกลิ่นมันจะแบบเข้ากัน
หอมมากๆเนาะบางทีเนี่ยจะได้จะได้ความหวาน
หอมเห็นมั้ยคะเป็นของหวานที่เวลาเรากิน
เราก็จะรู้สึกสดชื่นนะอืโดยเฉพาะร้อนๆแบบ
นี้เนาะนะเพราะว่าจริงๆแล้วเฉาก๊วยมัน
เป็นสมุนไพรชนิดนึงเหมือนยานะแต่กินคือ
มันมาจากต้นไม้นะเอามาทำนะก็กินแล้วเนี่ย
ดีกับคนที่แบบร้อนมากๆอากาศร้อนเนนะแล้ว
ร้อนในอย่างเงี้ยมากินอันนี้นะดีค่ะแล้ว
ก็ใส่น้ำตาลแดงลงไปเนี่ยกลิ่นมันจะหอมมาก
ความหวานของมันเนี่ยนะมันจะเข้ากับเฉา
ก๊วยดีมากนะครูบีใช่เพราะว่าตอนนี้ก็เข้า
ฤดูร้อนแล้วนะประเทศไทยนะคะอากาศร้อนแล้ว
คุณไปดื่มน้ำเย็นๆมีเฉาก๊วยเนี่ยคุณจะรู้
สึกสดชื่นแล้วก็
เฮ้อยากจะขออีก 1 แก้ว 2 แก้ว 3 แก้วใช่
ค่ะเนเชาก๊วยบางทีเขาก็ขูดเป็นเส้นๆเนาะ
ขูดให้มันเป็นเส้นก็อร่อยดีก็ใช้หลอดดูด
ได้อืเอันนี้ก็เป็นความหวานนะที่มาจากน้ำ
ตาลเช่นกันแต่น้ำตาลก็มีหลายๆแบบนะคะใช
ค่ะอันนี้ก็คือมาจากน้ำตาลมาจากอ้อยต้น
อ้อยนะนะแล้วก็อันต่อไปเนี่ยที่ครูุจะให้
ดูก็คือมาจากต้นมะพร้าวค่ะนะน้ำตาลความ
หวานที่มาจากน้ำตาลแล้วก็น้ำตาลที่ได้มา
จากต้นมะพร้าวค่ะนะซึ่งอมันจะหวานอร่อย
ค่ะโอ้โหเนี่ยเห็นมยเวลามันมันมันเตี้ยก็
โอเคพอเวลาเก็บไปเรื่อยๆเรื่อยๆก็จะสูง
ขึ้นสูงขึ้นแต่คนที่เค้าอันนี้เค้าก็ปีน
อันนี้มีบันไดนะแต่บางคนไม่มีค่ะปีนต้น
เลยค่ะอืนะปีนเพื่อไปหาน้ำตาลมะพร้าวนี่
หรอค่ะใช่ค่ะอันนี้คือเป็นดอกของของ
มะพร้าวค่ะเราเรียกว่าจั่นนะดอกมะพร้าว
เสร็จแล้วเนี่ยเขาจะเฉื่อนตรงปลายอ่ะค่ะ
แล้วก็เอากระบอกเนี่ยมาใส่นะเอาพลาสติก
หรือว่าเอาเอ่อกระบอกไม้ไผ่เนาะมาสวม
เพราะว่ามันจะมีน้ำที่ไหลออกมาจากดอกไม้
อันเนี้ยดอกของมะพร้าวเนี่ยจั่นมะพร้าว
เนี่ยค่ะนะเค้าก็จะแบบเก็บวันนึง 2 ครั้ง
ค่ะตอนเช้า 1 ครั้งแล้วก็เฉือนใหม่เฉือน
ออกไปอีกนิดนึงปาดทิ้งไปแล้วก็เอากระบอก
ใหม่มาใส่แล้วเา้าก็จะเอาน้ำที่ได้เนี่ย
ไป
ต้มอืนะน้ำที่ได้เนี่ยจริงๆเอาไปกินเลยก็
อร่อยนะครูบีเนี่ยเห็นมยอันนี้เนี่ยเป็น
ดอกของต้นมะพร้าวค่ะแล้วก็ข้างในอ่ะถ้า
เปิดมามันก็จะเป็นดอกแบบเมื่อกี้ที่นัก
เรียนเห็นเนาะนะอันนี้เค้าใช้ขวดพลาสติก
ค่ะแล้วก็มามัดห้อยไว้ให้มันน้ำเนี่ยมัน
หยดออกมาจากดอกคือมันได้น้ำออกมาเยอะขนาด
นี้เลยหรอครูปุ๊กแล้วแต่แต่ละพันธุ์มัน
ไม่เหมือนกันค่ะครูบีบางต้นให้น้ำเยอะบาง
ต้นให้น้ำน้อยนะก็อันนี้ถ้าได้น้ำเยอะ
ขนาดนี้ก็ได้น้ำตาลเยอะขึ้นน่ะค่ะนะเพราะ
ฉะนั้นเนี่ยเคือที่ที่ครูปุ๊กเห็นที่อยู่
ในในขวดพลาสติกเนี่ยที่เาเอาไปใส่เนี่ยก็
คือสามารถเอามาดื่มได้เลยก็ให้ความหวานใช
ใช่นะก็จะเรียเป็นเหมือนน้ำน้ำตาลสดแต่
ว่าจริงๆมาจากต้นมะพร้าวเพราะมันมีจากต้น
ตาลด้วยเหมือนกันนะอันเนี้ยก็คือเค้าก็จะ
เอาเนี้ยแหละน้ำอันเนี้ยที่ได้ถ้าเกิดเรา
ไม่ดื่มเนเพราะว่าถ้าเอาไว้เนี่ยมันจะ
เสียเร็วอือฮึนะเพราะว่ามันมันทำมาจาก
ธรรมชาติเนาะถ้ามันโดนอากาศโดนออกซิเจน
อะไรนานๆมันอาจจะเสียเร็วแล้วโดยเฉพาะ
ความร้อนเค้าก็เลยต้องเก็บเนี่ยวันนึง 2
ครั้งค่ะตอนเช้า 1 ครั้งแล้วก็เปลี่ยนตัด
ตัดออกตัดตรงปลายออกแล้วก็เอาสวมเข้าไป
ใหม่เอากระบอกใหม่มาสวมนะบางคนก็ใช้เป็น
กระบอกไม้ไผ่แบบเนี้ค่ะนะอันนี้โชคดีค่ะ
ต้น
เตี้ยไม่ต้องปีนค่ะ
นะแล้วใช่เา้าก็จะเอากระบอกไม้ไผ่เนี่ย
ค่ะเอาดอกเนี่ยมัดรวมกันแล้วก็เสียบเข้า
ไปให้น้ำมันไหลออกมาจากดอกนะโหยน้ำของมัน
เนี่ยหอมนะครูบีน้ำของมะพร้าวดอกมะพร้าว
เนี่ยค่ะแล้วก็ถ้าใครอยากดื่มน้ำตตาสดก็
ได้เลยเนาะอ่าเดี๋ยวครูบีให้ดูนะคะก็จะมี
ทั้งน้ำตาลที่มาจากเนี่ยค่ะต้นตาลแล้วก็
มาจากมะพร้าวเห็นมยก็ก็มีนะคะแต่มันต้อง
สดเหมือนเมื่อกี้ไงครูปุ๊กแล้วก็มาใส่ขวด
แล้วก็ดื่มเย็นๆแชรตู้เย็นอืมันจะยากนิด
นึงค่ะมันเสียเร็วเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยบางคน
น่ะเอาจจะต้องใส่อะไรสักอย่างนึงเพื่อให้
มันอายุนานๆน่ะเก็บไว้ได้นานๆ
นะเพราะว่าถ้ามันไม่ผ่านกระบวนการทำอะไร
สักอย่างนึงก็จะแบบกินได้ไม่นานค่ะแป๊บ
เดียวเสียเพราะฉะนั้นเอ่าเวลาเค้ามาเต้อง
เก็บปุ๊บเต้องรีบใส่ขวดแล้วมาขายเลยถ้า
เรารู้ว่าที่นี่เค้าเก็บเราไปเราไปขอซื้อ
เ้าได้ค่ะนะโอหถ้าถ้าบ้านครูปุ๊กมีต้นต้น
ตาลหรือต้นมะพร้าวแล้วก็มีน้ำตาลสดเนี่ย
คือรู้อยู่แล้วใช่มั้ยมีสวนมะพร้าวเยอะก็
อาจจะมีคนเนี่ยไปรอซื้อน้ำตาลสดดื่มก็ได้
เนาะอ่าอันนี้ก็ก็อาจจะขายด้วยหรืออาจจะ
เก็บเก็บไว้มาทำน้ำตาลก็ได้อ่ะใช่ค่ะแล้ว
เขาก็จะทำน้ำตาลก็ไปเอาไปเี้ยวเนาะในใน
ความร้อนนะเพื่อให้น้ำเนี่ยมันระเหยออกไป
นะแล้วความหวานมันก็จะจับตัวกันเหนียวๆ
แบบเนี้ยค่ะเป็นแล้วก็ใส่บล็อกคุณจะใส่
อะไรอ่ะใส่ในปี๊บเ้าเรียกว่าน้ำตาลปี๊บอื
ปี๊บมันก็จะเป็นเหมือนกระป๋องเหล็กอ่ะค่ะ
นะแล้วก็นะอันนี้ใส่ในถ้วยในชามอะไรอย่าง
เงี้ยมันก็จะเป็นออกมาเป็นเป็นก้อนกลมๆ
เป็นน้ำตาใช่ถ้าแบบนี้เ้าเรียกน้ำตาลปึก
อืมน้ำตาลปึก
นะหรือแบบนี้ก็ได้เา้าก็จะมีบล็อกที่เท
ใส่เทใส่ขนาดเท่ากันนะแล้วก็มัดถุงแล้วก็
เอามาขายนะคะใช่อันนี้ก็มาจากน้ำตาลมเช้า
เหมือนกันค่ะนะแล้วก็ความหวานที่ได้เนี่ย
มันก็จะมันๆอร่อยค่ะ
นะส่วนอันนี้ที่ครูปุบอกอันต่อไปนะความ
หวานที่จะได้ก็มาจากต้นตาลอืหรือบางคนมี
ตาลตะโนด
นะน้ำตาลโนดเนี่ยจะหอมอร่อยมากครูบีนะ
เมื่อก่อนตอนเด็กๆอ่ะครูปุ๊กได้กินบ่อยๆ
คุณแม่ซื้อมาให้กินเนาะแต่ตอนตอนโตแล้ว
เนี่ยไม่มีใครขายแล้วค่ะเพราะว่าต้นตาล
เนี่ยไม่มีใครปีนแล้วค่ะสูงเกินไปสูงมาก
นะแต่ตอนนี้เราเห็นที่ตลาดถ้าพูดถึงน้ำ
ตาลเนี่ยก็จะเห็นน้ำตาลมะพร้าวมากกว่า
เนาะที่ที่บางคนอาจจะเรียกเรียกว่าน้ำตาล
ปึกน้ำตาลปิ๊บอืที่ที่เห็นเป็นก้อนๆนะคะ
แต่น้ำตาลโนดเนี่ยหากินยากแล้วนะครูปุ๊ก
มากค่ะยากมากเพราะว่าต้นตาลเนี่ยแถวว่า
คือชลบุรีเนี่ยตัดๆๆๆๆใกล้จะหมดแล้วเพราะ
ว่ามันไม่มีคนปีนขึ้นไปเก็บไงอือาชีพคน
ที่ปีนขึ้นไปเก็บเี่ก็อันตรายเนาเพราะมัน
จะสูงขึ้นไปเรื่อยๆแล้วก็สูงมากนะสูงแล้ว
แบบตรงด้วยนะต้นตาลนะมันก็เก็บยากแต่ถ้า
เป็นน้ำตาลมะพร้าวครูปุ๊กจะเห็นเมื่อกี้
ที่ครูปุ๊กให้ดูรูปมีทั้งต้นที่สูงแล้วก็
ต้นเตี้ยๆเห็นมั้ยใช่คอมะพร้าวเดี๋ยวนี้
ก็สวนมะพร้าวที่เทำน้ำตาลมะพร้าวเนี่ยก็
จะเป็นต้นเตี้ยๆมากกว่านะคะอ่าสะดวกในการ
เก็บเห็นมั้ยคะใช่ค่ะไม่ต้องปีนใช่มยนะ
แต่ว่าน้ำตาลที่เราได้มาเนี่ยนะก็ทำ
เหมือนๆกันค่ะนะก็คือต้นตาลโตนดเนี่ยนะนะ
เค้าก็จะขึ้นไปปีนไปเอาแต่ว่าเค้าปีนแบบ
เนี้ยค่ะบางคนก็มีไม้ไผ่เนาะแล้วก็ใส่
แล้วก็ปีนขึ้นไปหรือว่าบางคนเนี่ยใช้
เชือกค่ะเชือกรัดแล้วก็
ปีนน่าจะไปดูฮอลลีวูดฟิล์มนะคะทาซานนะ
คะมันจะยากกว่าทาซานนะครูบีเพราะว่า
อันเนี้ยมันไม่ไม่สามารถที่จะโยนตัวเองไป
อีก้นนึงได้มันต้องลงแล้วก็ปีนขึ้นใหม่
แล้วก็ปีนลงแล้วก็ปีนขึ้นใหม่โอ้โหคือ
กว่าจะได้กินน้ำตาลโนดครูปุ๊กดูสิอันตราย
ด้วยกว่าจะขึ้นไปถึงโอโหต้นตาสูงมากนะคะ
ค่ะนะลูกตาลมันก็จะเป็นแบบเนี้ยค่ะถ้าเรา
ไม่เก็บมาเนาะหรือไม่ทำน้ำตาลเนี่ยเาก็
ดอกก็จะกลายเป็นลูกแบบเยค่ะสีน้ำสีดำๆแบบ
นี้นะเอามาทำขนมได้นะข้างในมันมีลูกตาล
อร่อยเหมือนกันค่ะนี่ค่ะเห็นมยเค้าปีน
ขึ้นไปนักเรียนดูใบใบของตาต้นตาลเนี่ยเขา
จะเป็นแบบนี้มันจะเป็นแฉกออกมาอย่างงี้เน
ใช่แล้วผู้ชายคนเเค้ากำลังทำเหมือนกันกับ
มะพร้าวที่เราเห็นเมื่อกี้อ่ะค่ะนะก็คือ
เอาดอกน่ะจั่นของมันเนี่ยนะแล้วก็ตัดปลาย
ออกนะเจะดึงเปลือกที่หุ้มมันจะมีเปลือก
หุ้มเขจะดึงเปลือกออกแล้วก็ตัดเพราะว่า
เา้าป้องกันว่ากลัวมันจะไม่สะอาดอืนะเขา
ต้องสะอาดไงนะไม่งั้นแบคทีเรียมันทำให้
เสียง่ายนะด้วยอากาศร้อนด้วยนะแล้วเาก็จะ
ต้องเข้าไปแล้วก็ใส่กระบอกแล้ววันนึงอ่ะ
เช้าปีนบาใส่ปีนต้องปีนต้นตาลสูงๆเหนื่อย
นะเหนื่อยกว่าจะทน้ำตาลถนดเนี่ยอมันสูงไง
นะแต่น้ำตาลถนดมันอร่อยมากหอมมากกว่า
มะพร้าว่ะนักเรียนแล้วมันโหครูปุก็คิดถึง
มากเลยอยากกินอีกแต่ว่าหากินไม่ค่อยได้
อ่ะบางทีเคบอกว่าอันเนี้ยน้ำตาลต้นมาจาก
น้ำตาลสดเเรียกน้ำตาลสดแต่จริงๆน้ำตาลเรา
คิดเอ๊ะน้ำตาลโนดใช่มยนะตอนนี้หาไม่ได้
แล้วค่ะอาจจะมาจากมะพร้าวหรือบางคนน่ะ
ซิกแซกก็มีเอาเอามาผสมค่ะกับอน้ำน้ำตาล
เอาอาจจะเอาน้ำตาลไทรขาวอ่ะค่ะไปต้มกับ
น้ำแล้วก็เอามาผสมแล้วไปต้มด้วยกันเพื่อ
จะให้มันปริมาณมันมากๆเนาะแล้วเอามาขาย
แต่จริงๆไม่ใช่น้ำตาลโนดไม่ใช่น้ำตาลสด
จริงๆนะแต่มีรสชาติหวานคือตอนนี้หากินยาก
เนาะอันนี้ก็เป็นความหวานจากน้ำตาลนะคะ
ใช่ค่ะเนี่ยค่ะแล้วก็ส่วนมากแล้วเค้าก็จะ
ทำทำออกมาเป็นก้อนๆแบบอย่างเงี้ยนะให้
อันเนี้ยอันนี้ก็จะเป็นตาลโตนดเนาะอืก็ทำ
ออกมาแล้วก็เอาอันนี้ทำขนมอร่อยมากจะหอม
อืนะนี่คแต่ก็อย่างที่บอกค่ะถ้าอยากกิน
เนี่ยต้องไปจังหวัดที่มีน้ำตาลโนดขายมี
ต้นตาลเยอะๆอย่างเงี้ยเนาะเพชรบุรีค่ะ
จังหวัดเพชรบุรีนะออันนี้จะได้กินของแท้
ไม่ใช่ของกอปปี้ก็ไม่แน่นะครูบีก็ไม่แน่
เสมอไปบางทีเนี่ยถึงจะไปใกล้แหล่งแล้วอ่ะ
ถ้าเราไม่ได้ไปที่สวนเลยเนี่ยก็ยังอาจจะ
เป็นแบบไม่ใช่น้ำตาลที่มาจากต้นตาลอาจจะ
เป็นน้ำตาลมาจากมะพร้าวอาจจะเป็นน้ำตาล
ที่ผสมน้ำตาลทรายอืนะอันนี้ก็นี่แหละค่ะ
ก็ต้องต้องหาซื้อดีๆเนาะอ่าแล้วก็เป็น
ความหวานที่มาจากหลายๆอย่างนะคะอ่าเรา
สามารถเอาไปทำขนมไปใส่เครื่องดื่มหรือไป
ทำอาหารได้นะคะแต่วันนี้หมดเวลาแล้วค่ะ
ครูปุ๊กอ้าหมดเวลาแล้วหรอโอ้โหครูุยังมี
ความหวานที่ยังเหลืออยู่โ้อได้แค่ 3
อย่างเนาะก็ไม่เป็นไรนะนักเรียนเราก็ได้
รู้จักความหวานที่เราเอามาใช้เนาะมาจาก
ต้นอ้อยต้นตาต้นมะพร้าวนะก็แต่จริงๆมี
ความหวานที่มาจากอย่างอื่นอีกเยอะนะคะอ่า
แต่เวลาเราหมดแล้วไงครูปุ๊กเราต้องลาทุก
คนไปก่อนค่ะตอนนี้อค่ะขอบคุณมากค่ะสวัสดี
ค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ